voici le terrain pointé du doigt selon
les analyses effectuées par la fredon en
août dernier le sol présente un taux de
chlordécone 11 fois supérieur au taux
admis et pourtant
l'agriculteur qu'ils occupent et cultive
encore patates douces et dachine des
produits vendus sur quasi tous les étals
des scandales sanitaires dénoncée par
l'association des consommateurs et
citoyens de la caraïbe toutes les
instances qu'elle interpelle par
courrier avec résultats d'analysés à
l'appui font selon elle la sourde
oreille
si nous n'avions pas réagi
moi je considère que c'est une non
assistance à personne en danger par
contre lorsque nous interpellons les
services de l'état lorsque nous était un
peu long elle est là pour la préfecture
et compagnie et que nous constatons un
immobilisme
pour nous c'est une complicité passive
ce n'est plus aux non assistance à
personne en danger celle d'une
complicité passive et symbolique forte
l'association des consommateurs et
citoyens dit avoir également transmis
les résultats des analyses à l'aso pas
marre elle non plus n'a pas répondu
pourtant depuis le mois d'août dernier
elle tente d'éviter l'expulsion dont
l'agriculteur fait l'objet dans ce
combat toute notion de présence de
chlordécone dans le sol et occulter
inquiétant pour l'association qui lutte
pour la préservation de l'environnement
ses membres ont même donné un coup de
main à la plantation
nous continuons à soutenir l'agriculteur
et nous disons que même une taie au clos
des gones est peut-être plate et mais il
faut savoir quel plantations faire donc
nous allons accompagner le et
l'agriculteur dans ce sens et puis aussi
nous disons que et bien il faudra
arriver a eu un accompagnement
institutionnel de ces cas là la
préfecture que nous avons contacté hier
nous a répondu ce matin via un
communiqué elle dit être au courant de
la contamination de sept parcelles du
nord noeud rouge depuis 2007
la date précise que les prélèvements de
la chine et de patates effectué le 2
juillet 2018 révèle un taux de
chlordécone inférieur à la limite
tolérée
sauf que les prélèvements de la fredon
qui affiche un taux bien au delà des
normes date du 9 août 2010 8 soit un
mois après les prélèvements de la daf et
pendant ce temps là ses patates douces
contaminé continue de se vendre à coup
de promotions